the experiment is over
the games have been played and the
athletes have held our gaze
the owner of gb's golden hat trick laura
kenny carried the flag
having carried off three gold medals in
the last
three games on top of that she'd just
watch
this jason kenny reminding the velodrome
who's boss the most intense ride
from the most laid-back champion he's
now
the most decorated british olympian ever
i just sort of went for it really you
know i didn't feel like i was one of the
favorites coming into the final
um you know i wasn't as quick as i
wanted to be in the sprint
and team sprint so i kind of felt like i
had nothing to lose and just put my head
down and went for it really um
it was such a long way i felt like the
last lap took me about half an hour
um but yeah i got there in the end i
couldn't believe i crossed the line on
my own still
the gold that completed the set came
from the red corner the first welsh
olympic boxing champion
lauren price had supreme focus
raised by her grandparents in south
wales her late grandfather
always on her mind after my fight um i
kind of locked up
and that's one thing i took with me out
here as well uh that he was looking down
on me
um a bit bit sad that he's not here for
me to get my mad along to him but
i know he he was the proudest man uh
ever and he would be the promised man in
the valleys tonight
when she makes it home she'll take with
her the final team gb medal
the 65th one of these games it equals
the medal tally from the home games in
london in 2012 and is just
too short of the extraordinary olympics
they had in rio
the pandemic though has made this so
much harder but the medal count
has remained consistent winning at the
olympics
is now just what team gb does
the paralympics start here in just two
weeks
and then in three years it rides into
paris
just the idea of a normal game so close
to home
means most of our star gb athletes
aren't quitting yet
leaving this stage is the hardest thing
for an olympian to do
tom parmenter sky news